oh yeah i was ready kiki palmer goes
filter free
and opens up about her health struggles
the 27 year old actress hit up instagram
tuesday to post a series of
makeup free selfies that showcased her
facial acne
and in the caption kiki opens up about
having polycystic ovarian syndrome
that she says has been attacking her
from the inside
out her entire life and she had no idea
adding quote my acne has been so bad
that
people in my field offered to pay for me
to get it fixed
the hustler star noted that she tried
the acne medication
accutane twice changed her diet and
even took blood tests to try and
determine the cause of her acne
quote it took me taking a personal look
into my family that has a history of
diabetes and obesity
to understand what was actually
happening with me
and kiki says that she hopes her message
will inspire others to be comfortable
in their own skin my skin has made me
sad
many nights but i do not give up on
myself
i know this is not me and my body has
been looking for help
i do not have a medical degree but i did
the research and took what i learned to
a doctor
and that led them to a proper diagnosis
so just what is polycystic ovary
syndrome
according to the mayo clinic it's a
hormonal disorder that can cause
infrequent or prolonged periods or
excess male hormone levels women with
pcos can
also fail to release eggs kiki ended her
caption with a heartfelt message
and a dash of her signature sense of
humor quote the least harmful thing
pcos can bring is acne to all the people
struggling with this
please know you're not alone and that
you are still so
[ __ ] fine my acne never stopped me
but we don't have to accept this now i
can really help
kiki and i love her so it's on oh
thank you girl but this isn't the first
time kiki has used her platform to speak
out on important topics this year
the multi-hyphenate has encouraged voter
participation
and lent her voice to amplify the black
lives matter movement
you know what dude we got to keep going
i i also want to say you know
everything's not going to always be
perfect but we have to really put on our
big
boy and big girl pants as the young
generation that's you know becoming the
new voters and the new people of the
world
we got to understand that we got to make
make do with what we have and really
figure out how to make a way out of no
way
and back in august she told et she has
been working on new music
to inspire her fans
i focused my mind and my energy on on
kind of creating this place of hope and
faith for
you know a better tomorrow and that's
what turned into the virgo tennessee's
part one ep which is
a collection of fun songs that helped me
get through quarantine that kept my
spirits high
and i just wanted to offer it to my fans
[Music]